Well H bot H bot is hyperbaric hyperbaric. They're oxygen therapy
caused herxine for late stage line
No, it shouldn't because H bot isn't
Isn't really going to cause
death to
Line bacteria H bot is going to increase oxygenation of your blood
That will help
With your brain and inflammation. I don't
Anything's possible with line, you know, so it's hard. You can't just say oh, no, not as you know
I've treated enough line patients at any any of the game. So
If you're going to do H bot, I would say start slow. I know typically at H bot
Session starts at an hour. You can start at 15 minutes. It's just
Wherever you're going for H bot see if you can start with shorter sessions to see how you tolerate